je pense je dis ce que je sens une cata
cette fille-là cette fille là c'est une
catastrophe
j'adorerais morale dont je veux pas
cette catastrophe est allé dire
complètement paumée elle est
complètement paumé il souhaite de ne pas
rencontrer des malheurs sa vie mais tu
es complètement paumé faut que tu te
retrouves le possible tu peux pas
arriver là et dire je t'envie mais dans
un hlm parce que tu es perdu tard et
elle a des cheveux lamborghini ans odile
buisson bas mais je laisse les trucs
intéressants que c'est mon cul tu es
perdu je sais même pas qu'il
y ait de l'ambition
mais regarde physique moi je t'ai bata
critiques sur ton sur ton est donné ton
faits dégueulasses
[Applaudissements]
rester corps est pourquoi alors est ce
correct mehdi lui ce que tu te rends
compte à la correcte et je pense que son
business est dangereux parce qu
il est bien ce que tu vraiment le
maître oui c'est l'eau de mon banc tu
veux comme mon père dit gemma de série
dans notre intérêt
au
caire fait combien de temps la tête de
toute la rue et donc du coup je souhaite
à tous nos atouts tonnes qui nous fuit
de justement d'avoir de l'ambition
d'être entrepreneur de créer des
entreprises d'avoir une mission
d'acheter des lamborghini fin je trouve
que c'est pour la vie
cela va finir non mais je suis ambitieux
au fait qu'est-ce qui te dérange c'est
vrai méchant mais c'est facile
d abonnés lors attendaient séparément
mais voilà ça veut rien dire
des choses avec ce que tu sais faire moi
demain c'est un truc est simple essaye
de gagner ta vie en mettant des baisers
entre l'éthique des cols roulés et là on
mord pas tu gagnes ta vie active
les sections fini tu parles
lahrech églises de suisse parce que des
gens qui croient en toi parce qu'elles
sont un peu paumé un peu perdu j'ai pas
combien tu as d'abonnés mais d'arriver
là et de dire moi je rêvais réussir ma
vie quand j'aurai une lamborghini rose
mais lamborghini jota
suspension mathieu mathieu n'est pas
d'accord avec rémi
si on paie pas et laurent guillou
qu'on répond d'abord elle travaille pas
question qu est
ce ça n'existait pas ton époque
qui ramène de l'argent est pas bon alors
c'était peut-être un connard quand
j'avais 20 ans je rêvais d'avoir une
porsche pas de lamborghini voile mais
d'abord sur ma gorge parce que là on est
libre je rêvais d'avoir voilà ça s'est
passé devant les basques qui rêvait oui
mais voilà alors et si j'ai pu en faire
à l'époque je leur ai fait six est le
casting de secret story ou août tarak je
l'aurais fait je rêvais de les gagner
d'argent se serait d'ailleurs sa ferrari
et la fia a laissé dire que tu ne
peux pas dire à des jeunes filles
regardent et fait voler des culots vont
pas de mentions légales a pas de statut
légal
du buzz mais kader et non